The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: Let me first
explain what the end art is.
The cover of The Economist
talks about a fundamental change
in economic use of
distance, arguing that,
if telephonic
communication becomes
free, what would its impact
be on societal life and space?
The second part is a book,
which now not very popular,
called Explorations
Into Urban Structure.
It follows a book
called Cities In Space,
which contains Melvin Webber's
classic article, which
I'll refer to, order
within diversity.
It's in the reading.
It's in the required reading,
so don't worry about it.
But the diagram on Figure 4
is taken from Explorations
Into Urban Structure.
This was an attempt
to make sense
of the complexity
of interchanges
in a contemporary
city, particularly
in the United States where
there are levels of--
this is an attempt to mark
a kind of new geography
of communication.
It's best read
about in the text.
I just put in this
diagram to remind you
that, if you ever got
interested seriously
in the creations of metropolitan
form and its options,
this is material that
you should access,
not that it promises
any solutions.
But like Melvin
Webber's argument,
it says that we need to take
more seriously a different kind
of attitude towards
metropolitan form
than that which is
conventionally supplied by--
I would use Webber's term a
bit later in a few minutes.
The next page is
two pieces of my own
written for the one conference
in New York on the downtown
conference from the
Rockefeller Foundation
for Urban Journalists.
So it's written in the kind
of hip way for discussion,
but it deals with material
on the American downtown
and the change.
It ends up with a
hypothesis that one
of the relationships
between downtown and suburbs
is a homeostatic relationship,
arguably, crudely speaking,
that the more you move away,
the more you will counterbalance
homeostatically.
And the growth of
the exurb in America
has been correlated to
a growth of the center
because the center has grown
rather idiosyncratically, given
that 25 years ago it was the
absolute destination of disuse
and [INAUDIBLE].
And the last piece
is a response I
was asked to give at a
symposium here at MIT where
Manuel Castells was awarded
the Kevin Lynch award.
And I took a kind of
nasty turn and had
to deal with the question
of whether information
technology would help improve
city and regional form.
I said some nasty things.
And a lot of people thought
that I was more correct
than the panelists.
But you can read it
in your spare time.
These are just
notes on the subject
that we're dealing with
in some ways or other.
Look, throughout
this class, I've
been giving you material not
for the sake of adding paper
to your compendium of stuff.
It's really got a couple
of reasons behind it.
Number one, there's
not enough time
to deal with all of the stuff
that I want to deal with.
And showing slides is
not an adequate way
of representing verbal dialogue.
It works when you are depicting
certain formal material.
And when you're
not, it's difficult.
Secondly, for those who believe
that this class will teach you
that there is a single
theory of city form,
I debunk that proposition.
We started this class with a
comment I made about the fact
that 1,000 miles from where
I was born archaeologists
named Broom, Dart and Tobias
discovered Australopithecus
africanus, the first major
transition from animal
to human dated 4
million years ago.
Brain size was 400
cubic centimeters.
Brain size today is 1,450.
I went through Robin
Dunbar's gossip theory
about brain size in 150
size communities and so on.
Discussions about the
city are very recent.
City's only 12,000 years old
even if we stretch the time
by 2,000 years.
I'd say it's more like 10,000
years as opposed to 4 million.
It took 4 million years
for the human brain
to decide to settle
permanently in a place.
And we are now 10,000
years in advance
of the first human settlement.
It's nonsense to assume that
we have worked out everything.
Boston has improved
in the period of time
that I've lived in Boston
significantly for most people.
For some people, it hasn't.
There is no single practice
of urban design in Boston,
which deals with the
metropolitan problems
of the city.
When the New England Patriots
decided to build a new stadium,
they didn't appeal to a
metropolitan authority
to decide where the maximum
location would be to benefit
the metropolitan area.
They went around to
every small town.
And they ended up in Foxborough
because Foxborough gave them
the best deal.
They then applied to the state
to pay for improvements in road
transportation to the stadium.
This is the way we do.
This is as much
theory as there is.
And you have to live with us
as practitioners and theorists.
God alone knows that they'll
be a consummate one theory.
We'll need a certain
set of agreements
that I can't foresee it.
Two of the topics that I'm going
to deal with today, the one
deal with the technology,
current technology,
and its effect on
metropolitan form.
One is the technology
of reducing distance
by virtue of systems.
And the other is the
advent of notions
that the way we are operating
at the moment in urbanism
is increasing the carbon dioxide
content of the atmosphere
and posing, if contested, risks
to the planet, which can only
be dealt with through
universal action.
You remember that I said
Woodrow Wilson arrived in Paris
in 1918, 1919, advocating
that the world join forces
in the League of Nations.
He received the
largest crowd gathering
in the history of Paris.
Of course, the League
of Nations didn't do--
we've done well in controlling
what my generation took
to the street.
And that was atomic
nuclear energy.
The nuclear bomb was our threat.
Computers weren't even
part of the human activity
in any mass way, but the
threat of the nuclear bomb
caused our taking to the street.
There would be no significant
use of nuclear bombs
since that time.
How is that we can agree on--
one of the questions
I would ask is,
what constitutes agreement
on matters which emanate out
of general goodness?
And our history of responding
to threats is very short.
Over the last month
in the United States,
we've tried to cause
people to remember
the death of 27 people.
I think it's 27 in
Connecticut, hoping
that the death of small
children at the hands of guns
would arouse enough enthusiasm
for some modest controls on gun
use in this country.
The Congress, which is
elected by the majority
of the population,
refused to even debate it.
As far as I know, given
that the mayor of New York
is on his last legs, not bodily,
but in terms of his tenure,
I would like to watch
over the next few years
what Hurricane Sandy is
going to cause in climate
prevention in New York.
I'd like to see all
of New York's suburbs
undergo an enormously expensive
proposition of putting all
the power lines underground
instead of in the air, which
causes enormous
disturbance of power supply
and so on and so on.
We're going to watch people
rebuilding on land which should
be used to soak up water.
This is still
happening in Florida.
We're very poor at
making decisions even
when we have significant threat.
Climate change has no
immediate significant threat
except for hurricanes in
New York and New Orleans.
But the correlation between
that and public response,
even when the body of science
is vectored to agreement,
let me just--
while we're talking about that.
There's a Professor
called Michael Mann
at Yale University.
He's one of the most
outspoken theorists.
He's a professor of
meteorology and geosciences.
Mann recently wrote a
book about his experiences
called The Hockey Stick
and the Climate Wars.
Over the last 15 years, as his
research has gained prominence,
he has been called a liar,
a charlatan, and a scumbag.
His critics have
demanded his erased.
Blogger Marc Morano called for
him to be publicly flogged.
Morano's former
boss, Rush Limbaugh,
said they should be
drawn and quartered.
This is in a democratic society.
His office at Yale has
been girded with police
and taped as a crime scene.
He's received threats to
himself and his family.
He has been the
focus of lawsuits
seeking the public
release of his emails.
Mann is arguably the nation's
most hated climate scientist.
I will argue that there are two
threats to urbanism in the form
that we are practicing it.
One of them is
fundamental change
in climate and
its repercussions,
particularly in the poor world.
The region around
the [INAUDIBLE]
is particularly
susceptible and one
of the poorest
regions in the world,
from Bangladesh all the way to
Iraq around to Southern China.
And secondly, the
question of social equity,
which I'll discuss
somewhat on next Tuesday,
these are the two
unresolved world problems.
The one is new,
human engineered.
The other is old and
human engineered as well.
There have been thousands
of books written
about the right of
us to achieve wealth
at the expense of others.
Marx contended
with that argument,
but didn't take into account
the pursuit of wealth and power
by the people who put
his theory into practice.
But I'll try to do some of
this summary more extensively
next Thursday.
Let's go back to the
American city and distance.
In my little comment
with Castells,
I quote from an article in Time
magazine, February 21st, 2000.
I quote, this is from the
architect Wes Jones's work.
"Computers promote a dramatic
trend towards decentralization,
allowing people to spread out
and live and work anywhere."
Now, my comment is
this-- despite the fact
that downtown residential
growth in US cities
is now at the same rate
as for metropolitan areas.
Secondly, the
vastness of cyberspace
increasingly satisfies the
craving for more space.
So the house and
yard will shrink
to a more supportable
size, this despite the fact
that the average US house is
now 50% larger than in 1970
while family sizes
declined by 20%.
It's unfortunately
true that architecture
borrows a lot of its
ideas for complex reasons
from people who decide to
make a solution to a problem
and then state it as fact.
It's impossible to take
Corbusier's writing
on the base of factual evidence,
yet he's the world's greatest
architect of the 20th century.
This discrepancy is
interesting because it
is associated with factual
observations such as these made
by young and claiming
to be on his way
to fame young architect.
Polemic and manifestos
and pamphleteering
don't reach the level of
Goebbels in Nazi Germany,
but they come close to--
I think it's part of the
notion of the whole complex act
of the brain in
producing architecture.
It involves so many
domains of knowledge,
which have to be brought
together and traded off.
And what gets traded off
in favor of many others
is the notion of creativity.
the notion of producing
unique resolutions.
When I did the architecture
education study,
it was interesting
to see how many
young people, young
architects or students,
say they chose
architecture because it was
both creative and respectable.
They had ability to be creative,
not work in a large corporation
and take orders
from above, which
most architects have to do.
But they pitted the life in
law and corporate business
against architecture because
architecture was creative,
but on the safe
side of creativity.
It wasn't playing jazz
or going to the theater
or going into painting or
going into media, whatever.
It combined rationality,
science, and art
in a unique way.
This has been the dogma
of architecture almost
since it started.
And it's created a
world of greatest.
Architecture is not
to be denounced.
But when it comes to
urbanism, the truths that
come from architectural
statements,
Mel Webber asks
the question, which
is an interesting question--
he says, "we have
often heard, I believe,
in taking the visual
symbols of urbanization
to be the marks of the important
qualities of urban society.
We have compared these symbols
with the ideological precepts
of order and found that
they do not conform.
And so we have mistaken
for urban chaos what
is more likely to be
a newly emerging order
to signal qualities of
complexity and diversity."
He's the limited
geometry that we have,
and I don't know how limited it
is given advances in computer
understanding, to
blame for the fact
that we consider to be
chaotic in urban form what
doesn't conform to our ability
to make formal sense out of it.
I don't know.
It's an irritating question.
I've had theses which have
looked at this over the years
and come to the conclusion
that it may be true.
But one of the advantages
of computational systems
is that it may yet be able to
associate form with complexity.
But as long as architects
keep on being trained
to work on the notions
of face to face contact
and visual order as opposed
to having order as equivalent
to architectural order,
I think we'll constantly
have problems of focus.
So Webber, who's a
great social scientist
professor at the University
of Berkeley, now retired,
raises this kind of question.
He says that--
I like to quote from writers
rather than paraphrase.
"It is now becoming
apparent that it
is accessibility
rather than propinquity
that is the necessary condition.
As accessibility becomes
further freed from propinquity,
cohabitation of a
territorial place,
whether it be a neighborhood,
a suburb, a metropolitan region
or nation, is becoming less
important to the maintenance
of social communities."
A fundamental question,
which is not yet resolved,
is the relationship
between the value of face
to face contact and
machine interposed contact.
Machine interposed
Goliaths claim
a minimum residue of importance
for face to face contact.
Although urbanists, particularly
architectural urbanists,
claim that higher density,
even the new urbanists who
don't even claim
for higher density,
claim that the geometric
propositions will cause people
to meet more frequently and be
friendly and have accessibility
and so on and so on.
Suburban life has not
lobotomized young Americans.
Most of you Americans
grew up in suburbs.
I'm not arguing for
the fulfillment of life
in suburban America, but I'm
arguing against the proposition
that they are dead.
There are other reasons
why American urbanists--
urbanism doesn't work.
There's a history to the
growth of suburbs in America.
They didn't occur all at once.
In fact, the latest
advent of computation
and virtual
communication is only
a new layer on a set of
facts that already the first
was already occurred
before the 20th century.
That's the advent
of the telephone.
You read the book The Social
History of the Telephone.
I think a part of it's
on your reading list.
Let me find it.
OK.
The telephone was
first introduced
to make living in the
non-city more tolerable,
so that people on
farms could have access
to health care in emergency
situations and communicate.
They were seen as the
people most deprived.
The advent of the
telephone created
two contrasting situations.
You couldn't have a skyscraper
without a telephone.
If you had to have people
running up and down
to communicate over
100 floors, you'd soon
have a bunch of tired workers.
In fact, secondly,
the rural population
depending on telephones
has become urbanized.
At the time of the
advent of the telephone--
it was prior to 1900--
70% of Americans
were farm workers who
lived in distant rural places.
Now, it's 3% of the population.
I haven't got the
text in front of me,
so I don't know if these
figures are absolutely correct.
Henry George Wells,
the British futurist,
almost exactly 100
years ago wrote
that electronic dispersion
would be accompanied
by simultaneous
decentralization,
this binary notion that the
more you do one thing the more
the opposite is accomplished.
Marshall McLuhan did it for
the arguing for the fact
that the cinema
would not disappear
given the advent of
television, that you
have a residual relationship
which is binary.
He specializes in cinema.
It becomes more of a spectacle.
It becomes more of an art form.
Television doesn't do that.
It occupies another niche,
although there are attempts
on television to do both,
provide spectacle and art
at the same time.
H. G. Wells wrote this 100 years
ago on electronic dispersion.
"The businessmen may sit at
home in his library and bargain,
discuss, promise,
hint, threaten,
tell such lies as he dare
not write and, in fact,
do everything that once
demanded a personal encounter,"
incredible insight.
This is before telephone
was even common.
"And so the center
will be essentially
a bazaar, a great gallery
of shops and places,
of concourse and rendezvous,
a pedestrian place,
its pathways reinforced by
lifts and moving platforms
and shielded from the
weather and altogether very
spacious, brilliant, and
entertaining agglomeration."
I couldn't think of a
better verbal depiction
of Moses King's depictions
of New York, which
we looked at on Tuesday.
And in fact, a Friday
night at 6 o'clock
in the evening in
downtown Boston,
when I was a graduate
student of your age at MIT,
Boston had virtually no
European based restaurants,
none of any quality.
When I was visited by friends
and family from outside,
I had to struggle to find
anything which wasn't made
of white bread and hamburgers.
Now, the number the turn over of
restaurants is so frequent that
I cannot go to a restaurant
which survives for longer than
a couple of years.
At least the number
of restaurants
that I used to go to
that have diminished
have turned over
enormously rapidly.
What has caused downtown
Boston to be attractive?
I list, in my piece,
a number of moves
both introduced by the
city and both introduced
by the change in culture.
Who would have predicted that
the United States would invent
the coffee bar, which you now
find in Cambridge, England
on the main street in one of
the more conservative zones
of the world?
Who conceived the idea of
inventing a coffee distribution
system in Seattle of all places?
These are curious
predictions, but they
have something to say
about the centralization
and decentralization
of the world.
What seems to be happening
is that the central parts
of our cities are
doing reasonably well
compared to where they were.
Manhattan was virtually
bankrupt 30 years ago.
I'm not getting my dates
absolutely correct,
but I'm guessing back.
At the same time, we
have suburban growth.
Suburban growth started
with the streetcar suburbs
according to the book by a
professor in urban studies.
AUDIENCE: Warner, yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Sam Bass Warner.
JULIAN BEINART: Sam
Bass Warner, yes.
I'm just confusing
names for the moment.
Sam Bass Warner's book
is obligatory reading.
The notion was that you
could move to Newton, commute
by street car suburb.
And if your wife
needed help, she
could telephone you in
the central business area.
And you could do something
about it as far as possible.
The moving outwards out
of the center of cities
has probably been a
doctrine of space form
since the beginning of
cities where it was possible.
If you could overcome
communication costs,
if you could survive
the onslaught
from people who wish to
take over your property,
if you weakened [INAUDIBLE]
premise that at the same time
is archaic man took information
from the celestial system,
he also had a notion
of centeredness,
that the center was important.
We've reduced the
notion of centeredness.
I think in my slides of
Boston City Hall Plaza
and in Giorgio's,
who's doing his paper
on the perceptual space
of Boston City Hall Plaza,
you get a redundant
configuration
of the use of center.
This redundancy is
part of a process
of interchange between
the outskirts and center.
We've reduced the
importance of centeredness.
I could read you from Fishman's
writing about a couple who
live in New Jersey.
He travels to New York
state every morning
on the freeway where he has a
job in White Plains, New York.
He teaches in a school 20
minutes south from where
they are in New Jersey.
The kids get dropped
off at school
or picked up by
automobile or buses.
They visit Manhattan, the
center of the universe,
once every six months to
take the kids to a museum.
They get The New York Times.
They watch television 6 hours
a day over weekends and so on.
This is a typical
contemporary suburban family.
They send their children
to university, probably
to good universities.
Because if you take
evidence from [INAUDIBLE],,
as I discussed on Tuesday,
people spend more time
on making sure that the kids
get the right form of education
in this class of people.
The dilemma in
this country is not
that people don't
care about education.
They either don't
have the capacity
to do anything about it and,
therefore, education is--
how do you understand the
paradox between the fact
that without any
doubt we have the best
universities in the world.
Duke University, which rates--
I mean, the rating
system is flawed.
But according to
the rating system,
Duke University is a second
rate university in the United
States, probably has one
of the best medical schools
in the world and so on.
How do you compare
the binary quality
of the higher level of
performance in our university
system and the weak, average
performance in our school
system, high school system?
How do you connect the two?
I don't know.
It's a proposition which has
to do with a number of factors
in this country.
And we haven't got
time to go into them.
But the move to the
suburbs was accomplished
by a number of things--
technology, the
telephone initially,
the septic tank,
which allowed you
to find a unit of
occupation independent
of a municipal system, waiting
for a municipal system to come,
the capacity of developers
to operate quite freely
to maximize profit, the advent
of the federal government
in believing that home ownership
was an important stability
factor in a good society.
Herbert Hoover and
Roosevelt endlessly
talk about the legislation
which allows Americans
to deduct real estate tax and
interest paid on their house
as factors in minimizing their
federal and local tax payments.
This works against
rentership, which
is a more flexible system,
which I pointed out on Tuesday
has advantages for newcomers.
Suburban growth, which manifests
a potential profit in home
ownership, must stand
in the way of bringing
in people of different color,
different capacity to pay the--
Bob Fogelson in the
Department of Urban Studies
has wrote a very
interesting book
called Bourgeois Nightmares.
I don't know if
you know the book.
It's a history of the restricted
system of American suburb.
He focuses on Pacific
Palisades, which
is a couple of kilometers
from downtown Los Angeles.
It was one of the largest
suburban developments
in American history.
It was designed by the
sons of Frederick William
Olstead, the greatest
American landscape architect.
It would not allow renters.
It would not like anybody
but the Caucasian race.
It virtually did--
you had to conform
to a profile of whiteness,
income, et cetera.
Restrictive
conditions were a part
of American suburban growth.
And only court
legislation much later on
provided equal access
to American suburbia.
So American suburbia,
like Newton--
well, I don't know the
history of Newton, but--
would be an adjunct
for white well-to-do
in the initial phases
rescued by the telephone
and the septic tank.
With the greater liberalization
of American space,
the suburbs took on an
independent economic force
of their own and
slowly disseminated
the distance and
time spent commuting
to the center of the city.
The first shopping centers were
in Framingham, Massachusetts
that led to larger sized
shopping centers, Mondawmin
in Baltimore ending up with
these gigantic complexes
in Minnesota and so on.
Work followed.
There are more offices
in northern New Jersey
than in Manhattan.
Believe it.
As the metropolitan
space of New York
includes northern New Jersey
as a metropolitan space,
as it should, there are more
offices in northern New Jersey
than in Manhattan, which is not
part of the human perception.
There's more commutation.
Over 50% of work
commutation today
is from suburb to suburb and
not from suburb to central city.
There are a number
of these indices.
The suburban world has become a
world of its own in one sense,
not dependent on
the central city.
Now, who would do you
expect to be in City Hall
Plaza on a Sunday morning?
Somebody living in Newton
watching television
for six hours having friendships
which can be accomplished
over large distances?
I want to recall an
incident in London.
A number of years ago, London
contemplated London road system
has never been
expanded significantly
despite the increase
in automobile use
quite [INAUDIBLE]
large proportion.
London proposed building a box
highway to make transportation
from southern parts of
London to northern parts
and eastern and western parts,
as the city was expanding,
more and more possible
without crossing
the center of the city.
All architects and
environments opposed this move,
saying highways were just
opportunities for more
automobiles, more
negative consequences,
aesthetic disfigurement,
and so on.
The New Statesman
which I used to read
and used to read because they
wrote such good English--
I learned to write
English from reading
newspapers, good newspapers,
not from any other source.
The first international
publication I ever published,
I rewrote 16 times.
So those of you,
especially those of you
who are foreigners,
believe you can
write a thesis in a week in
good English, forget about it.
Learning to write, like learning
to draw, is a slow process.
You assume that
you learn to draw
as architects in
five years and don't
learn to use language properly.
Anyway, that's beside the point.
But the New Statesman
had an editorial
which attacked the opponents on
the grounds of social equity.
It says that what we
know about social trips
is they're seldom done
by public transportation.
Social trips are generally
done by automobile.
We are depriving
the poor people who
are now having
access to automobiles
for the first time of the right
to access the metropolitan area
socially.
It would mean that
a young man who
lives in Wandsworth
in southern London
in a poor to middle income
community who meets a woman who
works in a same office
who lives in Hampstead
in northern London, if they wish
to date and there are no roads
to allow him to move freely,
that date will not take place.
Of course, it's debunked
by European examples
of people dating as a result
of subway encounters and so on.
But this was the argument.
The argument also applies to our
thoughts about climate change.
We've arguably gone
through a period
of building an economy
based on the profligate use
of resources.
Now, that we've
established our state,
we are now arguing for the
diminishing of the poor world,
who are arguing that
the distinction for them
is the choice between smoke
and income and survival.
It's an interesting
dialectic between the search
for social equity and the use
of the metropolitan space.
Just a few facts about
information technology
and urban space--
in 1997, only 6.3% of
the American population
worked at home on
a regular basis.
On an average, these people
only worked 19 hours a week.
Only a fraction of them
worked predominantly at home.
Less than half of the home
workers use computers.
The majority use telephones.
That was 1997.
I'm sure it has changed.
The notion of working at
home, the increase home work,
has an interesting counterpart
effect on automobile use.
Apparently, the more
you work at home
and the less you use roads,
the more opportunity there
is for the roads to be used
by people who don't use them
because of current congestion.
So there's an
extraordinary resonance
between reducing automobile
use on the one hand
by working at home and the
fact that those people who
work at home don't
use the automobiles,
reducing the amount
of use of the roads.
Therefore, the use of roads
is an elastic commodity.
Automobiles use roads when
it's easy to use them and stop
using them when there
are enormous difficulties
either in congestion
or in parking costs.
So one of the notions of
reducing automobile congestion
is having people live
close to where they work.
This is absolutely antithesis to
the idea of a liberal society.
Again, you have a problem.
You live in a metropolitan
area because you have access
to free economic opportunities.
Your husband and your wife
work in different places.
Much of this thinking
comes from pre-women work,
comes from suburbs such as
Levittown or Framingham,
where women didn't work and
had time for social life.
If the family that I described
from Fishman's article--
the husband maximized
his work opportunity
by working in White
Plains, New York
while they live in
northern New Jersey.
His wife teaches in school.
And the best job she can
get is 20 minutes south
of where they live.
So they have a 40 minute
spread between the two of them.
Americans change jobs
relatively frequently.
If you live in a metropolitan
area, changing a job
might not mean changing a
city or changing another part
of the metropolitan area.
Maybe if the road
system were adequate,
you could stay in your
house and change your job
because you can get freely
through private automobile use.
We'll just look at
one or two more,
and then we'll look at some
aspects of climate change.
I quote, "so far, cell
phones haven't directly
altered the look
of public space,
but rather provided more
flexible use patterns."
A study done of
Boston cab drivers
says that cab drivers
are relying more and more
on information from cell phones
than they are from teleradio.
They say it's full of static
[INAUDIBLE] interference.
The cell phone is more
timely and accurate
than anything that comes out
of the static played radios.
I never thought that cells phone
would make taxi life better.
An analysis of households
in North America that
perform online activities
weekly by activity
shows that 85% of the
internet is used for emailing.
The world's poverty gap
has doubled in 30 years
during the rise of information
communication technology.
Matthew Zook's analysis
of internet domains
in 2,500 cities
across the world shows
that the top five
cities, accounting
for 1% of the
world's population,
account for 20.4% over
all internet domains.
There's more evidence of
the centralizing effect
of information technology.
Our empirical work suggests
that telecommunication
may be a complement
to at least not
a strong substitute for cities
and face-to-face interactions.
This is not written
by architects,
but by urban theorists.
So we are currently
in a domain in which
we have to try to find
a reasonable balance
between face-to-face
communication
and its advantages in machine
interpersonal communication.
MIT is going crazy at
the moment debating
as to what extent
it should reward
students who learn
electronically,
from electronic information.
They have propositions
that it should shorten
the residential time at MIT.
MIT is based solely on
face-to-face communication,
not solely.
You're sitting with
computers listening
to face-to-face communication.
But the central
basis of the teaching
is still face-to-face
communication
and the limited population
who can benefit from it.
Over 36 years, I calculated
there have been 1,200-- no,
36 times 30--
1,000 students in this class.
Each of them is not--
there are now versions of the
class in India, in Moscow,
in Indonesia, one at Penn State.
A number of our
graduates of this class
are pleased about that, but it
doesn't compare to the effect
that the filming of the
class might have published
through MITx over time.
But the central domain
that you're living in
is to make sense in your work
of the still unresolved balance
between face-to-face contact,
which most architects prefer
and which most pre-computation
theorists have accepted
as the basis for their work.
Boston City Hall Plaza
is a good example
of reaching back into
the past to take account
of a development, which really
is proposed to take account
of the context of a
modern metropolitan area
rather than a historic
center of a city
where the density
of the population
and the amount of space the
population has have probably
arisen cultural
tropes of association,
face-to-face association,
such as in the Camp in Siena.
The Campo in Siena
has used the space
not only for individual contact,
but for communal contact.
The Palio twice a year
is a tourist event,
but it's also a competition
within the various neighbors
of the city to make more
of the center of the city
than it normally even provides.
What is the answer
to public space
in the contemporary
metropolitan area?
No public space?
Where is the public
space in Los Angeles,
one of the great cities
of the contemporary world?
Is there a square
in Los Angeles?
Yes, there is, but
it's not significant.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: It's
not a significant part
of the average Los Angelian
work or social life.
And yet it activates
enormous economic production.
It's not backward
in its social life.
It has one of the best symphony
orchestras in the United States
playing perhaps the most
advanced music in this country.
Hollywood hasn't gone
backward and died much though
how Adolf Hitler thought it
would because it didn't produce
a movie about the '32 Games.
These are fundamental
things that you
need to incorporate in your
work as an urban designer.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE] thesis
is a good substitution
for there are now
125 farmer's markets
in the metropolitan county
area, metropolitan area of Los
Angeles.
These are new adventures
which introduce
a form of public activity, a
decentralized form of public--
where commerce, which
is still probably
the foundation of
American public life,
is transformed into
a capacity to imagine
buying food from a
healthier provider,
a less-corporate provider.
There's a good thesis done here
about four or five years ago
on the farmer's market in
Los Angeles as public space.
So what I'm arguing
is that, above all,
the metropolitan area has
enormous advantages to us.
None of you would want to live
in small domains of 20,000
people unless if you
choose to live in,
unless you have enough wealth,
to live in Aspen, Colorado
where there are more private
airplanes at the airport
than any other city in
the world per capita.
One of the problems about
climate change is this.
It's not threatening enough.
The New York Times, and Time
magazine, and most publications
have had special
issues on greenness.
In The New York Times issue of--
I can't find the date.
It doesn't matter.
It's timeless.
This is a piece written by a
man whose titles his piece "Why
Bother?"
question mark.
"Let's say I do bother big time.
I turn my life upside
down, start biking to work,
plant a big garden, turn
down the thermostat so low
I need the Jimmy Carter
signature cardigan,
forsake the clothes dryer for
a laundry line across the yard,
trading the station wagon for
a hybrid, get off the beef,
get completely local.
I would theoretically
do all that,
but what would be the
point when I know full well
that halfway around the world
there lives my evil twin,
some carbon footprint
doppelganger
in Shanghai or Chongqing who
has just bought his first car.
Chinese car ownership is
where ours was back in 1918.
I forswear and who's
positively itching
to replace- so
exactly what do I have
to show for all my trouble?"
Now, this is an argument
in the developed world.
This man is writing
from his computer
in New York for one of the
world's leading newspapers
what to do, contemplating how
minimal his contribution is
in relation to the
[INAUDIBLE] problem.
The universality of
climate change and the fact
that it doesn't
demonstrate itself
in significant physical
form are two problems.
In the United
States, there is no--
when this professor
from Yale is attacked,
when Rush Limbaugh's
audience, who's
millions of people
in this country,
argues that Professor Mann
should be punished severely
physically is a sense of what
conditions occur when society
wishes to impose its will
for goodness on the economy
or individually.
Maybe this man who writes
for The New Yorker is wrong.
If all of us did something--
I commute by car to work
every day or every day
that I work because there's
no public transportation
to account for where I live.
I would have to walk
a significant distance
to get a bus.
I would have to change
the bus in Harvard Square.
And I live in the
center of the city.
[INAUDIBLE] has
taken the trouble
in Los Angeles in
her thesis to take
a trip from one of the poorest
areas by public transportation
to work.
She took something like an
hour and a half to get to work.
So we have a problem.
Public transportation is a
function of automobile use.
This is the world
in which you have
to start working in six
months time or two years time,
depending on how long you're
still going to be here.
It's not a pleasant world.
I am as much a bad citizen
as the man in New York City.
And yet I morally
proclaim a lot.
43% of carbon dioxide
production comes
from buildings, 25%
from industry, and 32%
from transportation.
The proposal to introduce
congestion pricing
in New York City within the
metropolitan area of New York
failed.
Why?
Because of democracy.
As long as people in rural
areas have significant votes
in situations which largely
are urban in character,
there will be this disjunction.
Road congestion
pricing in London,
which was accepted largely
because they had the best
public transportation system in
the world, as [INAUDIBLE] said,
failed when Ken
Livingstone, the mayor,
proposed attempt
to charge people
by the amount of carbon
dioxide the automobiles
or the vehicles produced.
Specialized congestion
pricing failed in London.
Congesting pricing has been
able to be imposed in societies
which have very strict
allegiances to the states,
such as Singapore, and will
become much more common.
I expect congestion
pricing to become
a phenomenon of modern
China, but have a slow advent
in the United States.
Just look at some
of these images.
On the left is a typical
proposition of mixed use
growth in American inner suburb.
"Steady on Judas," the phone
is ringing at the Last Supper.
And Botticelli's
Primavera painting--
"he wants a word in
your shell-like."
Next.
One of the attempts to
improve the monumental quality
of the freeway on
the left is a project
to change the shape of
the intersection in Italy,
a rather glamorous and
attractive infrastructure
change.
Next-- the proposition
which I mentioned
on Tuesday, which
we looked at at MIT
for the introduction of small
vehicles, which could operate
on the distributed system which
would be where the arrow points
to and also could transfer
to a line-haul system.
And it's an attempt to
design a interchange
to take the vehicle from the its
resistance, its temporary use
on the line-haul and
its circularly use
in the distributed system.
It's never been applied.
Next.
This is from the project
of Christopher Alexander.
"Every dwelling must be
immediately next to a vehicular
through--" This is
the maximization
of face-to-face contact.
"Each dwelling must contain
a transparent communal room
with the following properties.
On the one side,
the room is directly
adjacent to the street.
On the opposite side,
the room is directly
adjacent" to something else.
So all rooms in houses in this
project face onto the street.
And they are transparent.
And the road system is
on a number of planes
in order to maintain this
notion of actual and symbolic
face-to-face relationships.
Of course, it's
foolish in a silly.
But next, these are two sitcoms.
On the left is The
Brady Bunch, which
produced 117 episodes between
1960 and 1970-something.
It depicts urban condition.
This was their house, which
could have three, six children.
In suburbia, there
was no conflict
with the outside world.
You spread yourself.
This is a divorced husband
who was an architect.
His wife Carol had
three daughters.
He had three sons.
And the lady next to
Carol is the housekeeper.
This is the tranquil
American suburban situation.
I can read you some of
the episode stories.
They deal with personal
conflict growing up,
how to live in a
family, what to do
when somebody, one of the
children, is nasty and so on.
On the right is a subsequent
television sitcom called
Diff'rent Strokes.
I don't know if any of
you have seen these.
Diff'rent Strokes deals with
a man, a wealthy white man,
an aged man, whose wife died.
He adopts two black kids.
He has a natural born
daughter who's standing there.
The topics, the situation,
is in downtown American site.
The topics deal with
drugs, warning children
not to be attracted
in the street
by strangers, sexuality,
urban conditions.
They are two images
of the American,
the center of American
city and the good life
in the American suburb, which
is, of course, not attainable
for all of these happy people.
Somebody should write a piece
about the contrast between.
Ricardo, you should
take these two up
and indicate what they say about
American metropolitan life.
Who influences the ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in Mexico.
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I can give you a few
romantic examples in Mexico.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
These fascinate me
because they're created by
people who know America.
They're very interesting.
I mean, I had a
friend in Hollywood
who got me a site plan of
the set for The Brady Bunch.
I was going to write about
these two, but I never did.
Next.
Bill Mitchell's
attempt to denote
in a number of categories public
space retail transactions.
The category above is go there
same time, go there different
times, connect remotely, same
time and different times.
He's trying to indicate
what the space is where
we use face-to-face
communication and space which
can be connected remotely.
Next.
He talks the same in work.
The education--
classroom, lecture hall,
teaching laboratory,
design studio as opposed
to live broadcast,
videoconferencing class,
shared interactive
environments, Simnet.
Different times--
non-circulating
library, museum, language
laboratory and so on.
Next.
This is a project in Fort Worth,
Texas, which is essentially
a metropolitan project.
It's for Alliance Airport,
the first and only
passenger-free
airport in the world.
It's an intersection in
the metropolitan area
of Fort Worth of the
Highway 35, which
runs all the way from Mexico
to Canada, the Santa Fe
railroad which connects
Texas to the Pacific Ocean.
Next.
An airport which the
Perot group managed
to get done politically--
on the brilliant
idea that congestion
of goods when associated
with passengers
makes transportation of goods
very difficult. And next.
This is the American
Airlines' largest repair
facility in the world.
Federal Express chose
Alliance Airport as its--
after central
headquarters in Memphis.
Next.
I show this project not
because I worked on it,
but because it's one of
the few positive things
that could be produced in
a metropolitan frame taking
advantages of rail,
air, and train.
Instead, what we
now do in Boston
is schlep high octane
gas across the harbor
to the embankments in Chelsea.
This would reduce the friction
of that kind of communication
by locating facilities,
new kinds of facilities
such as transportation
or such as goods only.
You cannot send
goods electronically.
I was at a conference
in Euro Disney in Paris
once where a physicist
from British Telecom
argued that he foresaw a future
in which physical goods would
be able to be
dematerialized, sent
electronically, and
reassembled at the other end.
That will wait for
your generation.
I don't see the
physics being easy.
But this notion of
using transportation
where it works
well, where it can
connect in multimodal
possibilities,
is what Alliance.
And Alliance has
been very successful
partly because it's
been so well-designed.
It's got Texas steers on the
landscape next to the runways,
not in the way of the planes.
But it paid a lot of money to
making it a beautiful place.
It has rules for what
these industries can build,
and it's attracted anomalous
number of good clients.
OK.
We'll deal with the rest of
the world on next Tuesday.
Have a good weekend.